Utmost respect for snl.
Like,
you know,
people sometimes take shots at them.
Um,
but I mean I think that's a great show
and I feel like the cast right now,
they have like a smaller,
tighter tasks and it's actually like,
I really feel like one of the strongest
casts that that they've had in a long
time.
And,
um,
you know,
I always feel like people aren't
catching that show every week.
It's only because I,
there might be a perception that like,
oh,
this is this,
this legendary show.
And,
um,
people may feel like,
oh well they'll catch it whenever.
I feel like some of that is due to like
what we were talking about,
the changing nature of how people are
finding stuff.
You know,
people watch stuff on the internet and
stuff like that.
But,
um,
I feel like right now that cast is
totally strong and solid and like pound
for pound I sure like always makes me
laugh.
I mean,
there's always something funny every
week on that show.
I think.
I think the challenge of,
of doing some stuff on that show is just
the fact that,
um,
that it's a live show every week.
I mean it's really hard to do a live
show every week.
And people,
I think people kind of think like,
um,
that's not impossible.
It is,
I'm sure probably impossible to pull
that off.
Um,
it must be exhausting.
So,
um,
yeah,
I always feel like,
um,
you know,
but the thing about comedy is that like
not everything ever hits,
you know,
I mean,
comedy is completely subjective.
You know,
no one likes every single thing that we
do.
Um,
a lot of people don't like any of those.
We'd be like,
my mom,
hey,
sorry,
show my mom told me over Christmas that
she was like,
we were talking and she goes,
um,
I said something about our show coming
on and my mom was like,
um,
I'm thoroughly embarrassed by your show.
I was like,
what?
She's like,
I think it's crude and it's a vulgar,
and it is,
I guess it is crude and vulgar,
but,
um,
but you know,
it's,
it's purely subjective.
And that's the thing with snl too,
like,
um,
you know,
people watch that and some people will
be like,
oh,
I didn't get it.
But it's like,
well,
comedy is subjective.
Like not everything is going to hit with
you,
but,
um,
yeah,
that shows,
I always feel like that shows
got some funny,
funny stuff.